college students headed back to campus
this fall will help familiar guidance
about kovid and new warnings about
monkey pox the cdc has recorded nearly
17 000 monkey pox cases nationwide white
house officials spoke with university
leaders yesterday about this outbreak
meg oliver looks at the ways colleges
are preparing for yet another public
health emergency
hofstra university in hempstead new york
is prepared for monkey pox if it arrives
here in the fall our team is practice
this we're ready for this and this is
what we do every day
executive director of student health
services rob stahl says they've ramped
up cleaning and disinfecting protocols
to help stop the spread the good news is
that monkey pox is
not like covent in that it is not as
easily spread it is not spread through
small droplets it really requires much
more prolonged contact of the some 17
000 cases nationwide new york has the
most of any other state followed by
california florida and texas how are you
educating students so we have posters up
in
all the bathrooms on campus as well as
common spaces on campus that students
are in and would access and also
providing them information about health
and infectious disease in general and
how they can best prevent themselves
from getting sick while they're here at
college that also includes having
testing in place for students who might
show symptoms like fever and a
characteristic rash monkey pox is
primarily spread by close contact with
individuals that's skin to skin skin to
mouth mouth-to-mouth type of contact
amish adultja is an infectious disease
physician and senior scholar at johns
hopkins bloomberg school of public
health he says schools like hofstra are
doing the right thing by making sure
infected students have somewhere to stay
for a while they need to make sure that
they have ways for students to isolate
in a comfortable manner for a couple of
weeks if necessary is that feasible for
most universities to isolate students
for up to two weeks what we know is that
universities really had to reconfigure
their operations because of kova 19 and
they always had isolation dorms and
isolation rooms but overall adulja says
the risk for universities is low i don't
necessarily think this is going to be a
disruptive force on college campuses but
it is something that colleges need to
proactively plan for so it isn't
disruptive
we reached out to more than 30 schools
for this story and while many were
making some kind of preparation mostly
sending informational emails to students
none expressed that monkey pox was as
dire a concern as the covet 19 pandemic
jamie that's good i hope they have plans
in place meg thank you